as the country grapples with the covet
pandemic another public health crisis
it's getting worse homicides involving
firearms rose 33 percent from 1999 to
2019
and unofficial data shows 2020 likely
had the highest rate of gun deaths in
the past two decades and that was during
the pandemic when we're on lockdown
researchers research shows that
community intervention programs
can reduce gun violence by up to 60
percent the biden administration has
earmarked
5 billion from the american jobs plan
for those programs
the president made that announcement
back in april in front of violence
prevention leaders
like erica ford our dr tara narula shows
us how ford's non-profit in new york
is trying to make a difference tara good
morning good morning gail
instead of debating gun control and the
second amendment erica ford's non-profit
called life camp
focuses on fixing the root causes of gun
violence
by offering community support and
positive alternatives
through sunny playgrounds and shadowy
corners of south jamaica queens
this bright orange peacemobile helps
keep the peace
by offering a safe space for the
community to connect
with words
or without life camp believes
that a healthy mind and healthy body
healthy spirit
can lead to a peaceful life for more
than 30 years erica ford and her
non-profit
life camp program have intervened in
moments of conflict
and promoted peaceful alternatives to
picking up a gun
there's tools and things that we can use
to just cool off when
things get pressured we have to get the
right medicine to a person so
if it's a job if it's yoga if it's
meditation
if it's therapy there's various
different
prescriptions 45 people were shot in
this neighborhood last year
the most since 2012.
growing up here ford saw the need for a
response that took aim at the roots of
gun violence
trauma is in the beginning the middle
and the end of violence
and so no one wants to pick up a weapon
and and bring harm to somebody it is
something happening inside of
a person that triggers them to make the
wrong decision
why do you think it's important for
people in the neighborhood
to be part of solving this problem those
who are closest to the problem
are closest to the solution so you go
wherever the need is
so when you drive in and interrupt an
incident and park your peace mobile in
between what's the reaction that you get
um first of all it's shock and then
they'll tell us
oh we don't want to hear that peace
stuff we're not hearing that peace stuff
and i got you but we can't afford no
more gun shots
carl fuller is both the driver and
driving force behind life camp's vessel
of hope
now all we asking you to do is not shoot
but that one moment that you get
somebody not to shoot
is a success this spot we're standing at
right now is the very spot
my son was killed fuller's son carl jr
was shot
and killed in 2007 just after graduating
high school
my wife died eight months later of a
broken heart
fuller turned his grief into activism to
save other families from gun violence
and its ripple effects
a lot of fathers are not willing to
share their pain
because in this community a man is not
allowed to cry
the only thing that's tolerated from me
in this community
is anger there was a man coming around
the corner with a gun
and before i could do anything he had
shot my son
seven years ago right before her eyes a
stranger shot carolyn dixon's son daryl
lynch
in a dispute over a parking spot
did you fall asleep life camps
therapists helped dixon
process her grief why is it so important
to take that holistic approach
because you can't fix one part of the
body without fixing
all everything comes together as a whole
at their dream cafe jaquiel johnston and
jayton macmillan
used ford's lessons to help neighbors
heal from the inside
out so we had our fair share of violence
we had our fair share
of bad eating ultimately it's been a
tradition you know
when they were teens life camp
introduced the lifelong friends to a
healthier and safer lifestyle
now they're paying it forward i lost my
dad
and not only my dad i lost plenty of
friends as well like to gun violence you
know
you have to create solutions instead of
complaining
and waiting for somebody to change the
community that we're from
they were able to change the narrative
of what was cool in their community
so people went from the chicken greasy
spot
to now eating healthy and doing yoga in
the park
as opposed to you know shooting each
other or selling drugs
the people in our community have a right
to live free from suffering
they have a right to live free from
violence
ford is looking to replicate her program
across the country and create what she
calls an
industry of peace she hopes her work can
inspire other programs to build holistic
approaches
to ending the cycle of violence ford
told me that she chose the color orange
for her work
because it is bright and told us when
you see so much blood running through
the streets
you want something to give light to
people and you're representing the
orange today thank you erica ford and mr
fuller in the dream cafe
but you think it's important that we see
gun violence as a public health
issue right absolutely gail and there
are so many people leading this crusade
to get us to de-politicize this issue
the same way that we tackled car crashes
in car safety for example
with science and funding and all the
people who need to be at the table
talking about this and working on it
great reporting really great
and i want your dress we'll be right
back